president biden is beginning a four-day
visit to the middle east planning to
meet with leaders of israel the
palestinian authority and saudi arabia
all with an eye on regional rival iran
and ed o'keefe has made his way to
jerusalem traveling with the president
this is the president's second stop on
his tour of that region ed good morning
to you
what's in store for the president over
the next few days
tony good to see you the white house
points out this is the president's tenth
trip to israel over the course of his
career his first as commander-in-chief
he's set to arrive here in about an hour
and we'll get a look at israel's
anti-missile defense systems and later
make a visit to the country's national
holocaust memorial but broadly over the
course of this week it's about warning
and isolating iran and its nuclear
ambitions here in israel he's set to
unveil a new joint u.s and israel
agreement committing to never allow iran
to get a nuclear weapon both countries
set to say they'll use all of their
power to stop that from happening and
notably ahead of the president's arrival
russia's president vladimir putin
announced he will visit iran next week
that comes as the biden administration
says iran is set to give russia armed
drones for its invasion of ukraine once
he leaves israel on friday the president
is set to go to saudi arabia to attend a
regional conference and meet with that
country's king and its controversial
crown prince mohammed bin salman
gail
he raised a lot of eyebrows over that
one thank you very much ed o'keefe